good afternoon everyone are there any
questions so far about anything any
science any mechanics in the course any
any time you have a question even during
the time I'm talking you're welcome to
ask it I don't mind okay don't have to
wait till later yes yes sorry right what
do I recommend doing so the format of
the test will be short answers I'll put
up last year's test so you can see the
format it'll be different will I'll give
you some study questions beforehand it
will cover what's in the lectures
nothing outside of the lectures I want
to ask you anything that's in the book
that I haven't covered for example
alright and I try to emphasize on the
quizzes every week what I think are the
important points so those will be the
focus of the exam among other things as
well so I think if you just concentrate
on what we do here if you can listen to
the lecture a few times it really helps
to reinforce it because once is often
not sufficient but you'll know what I
want you to learn like today we have
some slides which show exactly what I
want you to get away from this ok
anything else yes it depends when I put
them up so I didn't put the ones up till
last night so there you get a week each
time basically it's a week yeah and if
you don't make it for whatever reason
just tell me and I'll open them up again
okay
anything else it's really my goal in
this course is to have you learn biology
okay I think that's the most important
thing I unfortunately have to give you a
grade so I have to figure out a way to
do that but I want you to enjoy it and
get the most out of it just the good
thing is when the course is over it'll
be warm right yes I think when you start
it there's a little red number in the
upper left that says you have until so I
just started taking one and it said yeah
I have till 6 p.m. so I give you a
couple of hours if you can't finish it
every two days because there's only
three questions so it's not a probably
know then each one will be two lectures
so it's not going to be any more than
six or seven questions so you have
plenty of time to do it but if you have
a problem you know and you want to redo
it just tell me because I want you to
use it as a learning tool okay all right
today we're going to start talking about
viral genomes you know what genomes are
of course the genetic material we're
going to talk about the different kinds
of structures there are and viruses and
then we'll talk about genetics how
experimentally we can manipulate these
genomes to do various things to
understand viruses to prevent infections
and to prevent other diseases as well
again remember we talked last time in
the 1950s there was a breakthrough in
virology
where it was found that the nucleic acid
genome carries the information needed to
make new virus particles so it's the
genetic code and that was previously
figured out for DNA and bacteria in the
40s but viruses were perceived as
different and it wasn't until the 50s
that this was sorted out so this is very
obvious to us now right nucleic acid is
the genetic information but back then it
was a debate very interesting things
change and the experiment we talked
about the other day the hershey-chase
experiment with bacteriophage t4 which
is this one right here was an important
part of that conclusion that the nucleic
acid is the genome but also work with
tobacco mosaic virus
which we'll talk about in another
lecture and this is the first virus to
be discovered remember it's the virus
that causes the mottling on tobacco
leaves so over the years as people
studied biology they discovered
thousands of different kinds of virions
different infections of all forms of
life and but in the end it turned out
there only a finite number of viral
genomes and that's going to be a focus
of what we talked about today there are
just seven different genome types so
commit that number to memory it's very
easy lucky number 7 genomes so if I ever
ask you how many different viral genome
types are there dr. Silverstein seven
not a lot seven different genome types
and that's it and that makes it easy and
you there either DNA or RNA that's it as
far as we know nucleic acid doesn't come
any other way seven types DNA and RNA
this is why I teach virology the
composition and structures of these
seven genome types are more varied than
anything else in any other kind of
organism bacteria fungi protozoa
whatever more varied in viruses than any
other that's why they're so interesting
to study in part and they're very these
are very simple organisms if you will
but the decoding tactics are diverse we
see every possible tactic for encoding
and encoding information that is the
nucleic acid encodes information encodes
protein
it also has non-coding regions that are
important which we'll talk about but
there are many ways you can do this and
viruses have done it all different ways
and in terms of molecular biology the
genomes have provided an almost
unlimited source of subjects to study us
whenever we study a virus we discover
something new so the amazing diversity
is very fulfilling the RNA and DNA
genomes are structurally very different
here are some of the different kinds of
structures that we see in viral genomes
so they can be linear which means a
single molecule with two free ends
as opposed to a circle where the ends
are joined of course it can be segmented
that is they can be in pieces they can
be 2 or 4 or 8 or 10 different pieces in
the virus particle they can be gapped we
will see examples of that in other words
mostly double stranded but in some parts
it's just single stranded because
there's a gap on the other strand it can
be single stranded positive polarity
they can be negative polarity of single
strand it can be ambi sense which means
they have both polarities on the single
strand we'll see how that works they can
be double stranded as well and some have
proteins attached to the genomes and
some have the ends cross length we'll
see examples of all of these as we go
through talking about specific viruses
and some even have DNA with RNA attached
to them so this does not occur in any
other organism except viruses this
diversity of genome structures pieces
not chromosomes because that's got a
specific meaning but they have different
pieces of genome packaged in the
particle and they're all and they're all
important for the virus to replicate not
just one piece of DNA or RNA but
multiple pieces so that's what we mean
by segmented now why is the question why
are there so many ways of doing things
we have mammals have double stranded DNA
genomes well our mitochondria have some
single-stranded circles but for the most
part our coding information is in
double-stranded DNA but why do viruses
have such diversity can it tell us
something about the biology of the virus
or how they have evolved by studying
this diversity is one way of encoding
information better than another so is
double stranded DNA better than
single-stranded RNA maybe for you the
most important thing is do we have to
memorize all of this you don't actually
have to because after you understand if
you start at 7 different genome types it
will all come from that and so you don't
really have to memorize it but I will
ask you how many different genome types
there are some of these questions are
hard to
answer why is a given structure in a
genome used well sometimes that reflects
how the genome is packaged how it's
expressed and we'll give some examples
of that in the course so a certain
structure in a genome may be important
for the replication cycle and that's why
it's present but we often don't know why
things are there why are there still
double stranded viruses and double
double stranded DNA viruses and double
stranded RNA viruses we have no idea why
they're coexisting now it's an
interesting question why we have viruses
with both kinds of genomes as I said we
and other mammals have DNA based genomes
but the RNA world is different and there
is a hypothesis called the RNA world
hypothesis which say that RNA genomes
were the first to appear in evolution so
out of that primordial soup many many
years ago the first genomes to appear
were actually RNA and there was a whole
RNA world that lasted a long time where
organisms were based solely on
ribonucleic acid not DNA today the only
RNA genomes left are viral genomes no
other organism has an RNA genome except
the viruses so one question is are these
relics of the RNA world so maybe a
viruses are really old and they're
giving us a glimpse at what was around
in this so called RNA world which is of
course is hypothetical and if so if
there was an RNA world why was there a
switch to DNA and why did that
predominate for all forms of life except
viruses we can't answer most of these
questions but they're very intriguing
and these are not the kinds of I
wouldn't ask you on an exam
why did DNA supplant RNA because we have
no idea all right but it's an
interesting it would be interesting but
that would probably be for another
course so you need to memorize some of
this stuff you need to memorize the
seven different genome types but as soon
as you do that
how they work will be evident so what
information is in a genome well gene
products proteins and signals that we
need for replicating the genome
obviously for assembling the capsid and
packaging the genome in
to it and also things to regulate the
timing of the replication cycle you will
see in the examples that we talked about
the replication cycles of many viruses
are regulated things don't just happen
all at once for many viruses they happen
in a very orderly fashion and that's
encoded in the genome as well there are
gene products to modulate host defenses
as we mentioned briefly the first time
viruses wouldn't be around if they
couldn't overcome host defenses we have
great host defenses and there are a lot
of proteins that have this job and
finally the gene the genome encodes
proteins that allows the viruses to
spread to other cells and hosts so all
these things are encoded in the genome
but there are also things that are not
encoded in genomes and looking at those
can be instructive as well for example
no virus has a complete protein
synthesis machinery the Mimi virus is
the really big viruses have some genes
encoding T RNAs and other parts of the
machinery but no one virus can translate
on its own and that's why there are
parasites of the host translation system
some of our as I said encode RNAs and
proteins involved in translation there
are no genes encoding proteins involved
in energy production which viruses
require of course or membrane
biosynthesis so viruses require energy
to replicate and they can't make it they
can't make ATP they have to get it from
the host cell
they also many viruses also use
membranes they can't make those either
they tend to depend on the host cell to
make those as well
there are no classical centromeres or
telomeres that are found in standard
host chromosomes so the telomeres at the
ends of the chromosomes in our genomes
for example we don't find some an exact
duplicate of those in viruses but in all
these cases you could argue that we
haven't found them yet
so this is what we know but it could be
in a year or ten years we find viruses
that are exceptions to these rules but
as we stand today we don't have genes
encoding any of these things okay so
this will make your life easier and I
told you this before viral genomes
make mRNA that can be read by host
ribosomes if you keep that in mind you
will be able to trace the expression of
a genome knowing what the genome
structure is and I'll show you how to do
that over the next few lectures so keep
this in mind there's seven genome types
but they all have to lead to mRNA and
that's what Baltimore used to make his
very interesting classification of in
1970s where he took all the genome types
and showed how they led to mRNA so mRNA
is central you have to make mRNA because
you have to make protein as far as we
know the only way to make protein is
through a translation of mRNA so these
are the seven genome types and as I said
he originally noted six because that's
what was discovered at the time and then
later on the seventh genome type which
is the gapped double-stranded DNA of the
hepatitis B viruses was discovered so
this is a very good scheme to understand
and perhaps even commit to memory
because it will help you understand how
the viruses replicate so some
conventions also that you should
memorize mRNA is always the plus strand
by convention again someone decided X
years ago we're going to call mRNA the
plus strand someone asked me once if it
has to do with electrical charge no it
doesn't negative has nothing to do with
charge it's just mRNA translation plus
it sounded good but in another universe
it could have been - right DNA of the
equivalent polarity is also the plus
strand so if the DNA if it were RNA then
it could be translated it would be the
plus strand so that's keep DNA of the
equivalent polarity RNA and DNA
complements of that plus strand are
simply called negative strands we use
this a lot in biology that's why we're
going it over it again now mRNA is
ribosome ready
so mRNA is plus stranded it can be
translated directly into protein but not
all Plus RNA is mRNA not all plus RNA
has the structure that allows it to be
translated into protein but if it's an
mRNA you it is automatically plus
stranded
so here is the secret to success in
virology
there are only a few ways to copy these
genomes these seven genomes to produce
mRNA the the number of ways to do this
aren't infinite and that makes your life
easier because you can remember them all
in fact it's logical with knowing a few
facts you can deduce the pathway from
any genome type to mRNA the key here is
that each pathway whether we're starting
from double-stranded DNA or
single-stranded RNA has its own
polymerase the nucleic acid enzyme that
copies the nucleic acid has a primer
that has a template and termination
requirements so each pathway again from
those seven different nucleic acids have
unique combinations of these things and
you can deduce those really once you
know the rules each virus family sticks
to one strategy so a virus family is
made in part the classification is done
according to the nucleic acid so the
picornavirus family for example all have
plus stranded RNA genomes so they will
all follow the same strategy from their
genome to making mRNA so you don't have
to worry that within a family you're
going to have to understand different
strategies we will typically say okay an
example of a popcorn of viruses
poliovirus and we're going to teach you
how this virus replicates in a cell and
that will apply pretty much to all the
other viruses in the family now this is
a particularly nice figure that I found
which shows these seven classes of
genome and it shows how they replicate
so here are three different kinds of
viruses aren't viruses with RNA genomes
viruses that reverse transcribed their
RNA that means they take the RNA and
make a DNA copy and then there are the
viruses that have DNA genomes and the
RNA viruses here genome replication
cycle this is a nice cartoon that shows
you that all you have to do here is go
from RNA to RNA so the virus RNA comes
in the cell has to make more RNA and
more RNA etc quite simple the contents
of the virions the RNA viruses can be
plus or minus single-stranded RNA or
double-stranded RNA so that breaks it
down makes it very simple and then at
the bottom there are some examples of
the kinds of viruses that fall in here
all right then we have our reverse
transcribing viruses these are viruses
with an RNA genome or some cases a DNA
genome and they go back and forth from
one to the other but again within a
virus family it only goes in one
direction so the retroviruses have an
RNA genome they make DNA out of it
the kepada of irises have a DNA genome
they make RNA and then DNA using reverse
transcriptase okay so the reverse
transcribing viruses simply means you go
back and forth between RNA and DNA and
the these are two examples or retro
viruses like HIV and the hepatitis B
virus they have different genomes in the
in the virion the retroviruses have an
RNA genome that's plus stranded now you
may say why aren't these the same as
these plus stranded RNAs well because
these have a reverse transcriptase and
they have a DNA phase in their life
cycle these viruses do not and finally
we have DNA viruses that simply go from
DNA to DNA to replicate their genomes
and these can be in the virion
either single-stranded DNA where
double-stranded DNA they can be circular
or linear so I find this useful to
summarize this with some examples that
goes beyond the Baltimore table so I
think you ought to memorize the seven
genome types but you can already do it
almost because if you just think of
every possible configuration of nucleic
acid you already have it done and that
will help you understand how the genomes
are expressed so don't wait till the
night before the first exam you should
start now you should start thinking what
are the seven types can I remember them
because if you know the structure you
can deduce how mRNA is made and how the
genome is copied to make more genomes
and that's something that I want you to
know at the end of this course now the
textbook is useful for this because it
has a lot of illustrative material that
helps it has so in Chapter three the
chapters called genomes and genetics
which is what we're talking about today
it has figures which summarizes
everything I've told you and in in that
after for each of the seven genome
classes there's a box that has essential
information it tells you the genome
configuration how much the virus depends
on the host for replication this is a
key point that we'll be talking about a
lot some viruses are very dependent in
others less so and gene expression
strategy so all of this is in Chapter
three following each of the seven genome
strategies and this is an example of one
of those figures so at the top of this
figure you have single stranded DNA
genomes so that's one of the seven
Baltimore classes has a little picture
of the single-stranded DNA two examples
of families of viruses that would have
this kind of genome and you can tell
that a word is a family name because it
has a e at the end CR Co viridi and
parvathi Rd and then at the top here it
has the strategy by which the genome is
not only made into mRNA but is also made
into new viruses so here these single
stranded DNA genomes they can be
actually either minus or plus stranded
they're copied to double-stranded DNA
now you ask you may ask why would you
automatically assume that you have to go
from a single to a double stranded DNA
genome well you have to know one fact
and that is you cannot make mRNA from
single stranded DNA so if you know that
you'll be able to figure out when you
see a single stranded DNA genome that
the first step that has to happen is it
has to be converted to double strand so
that's what happens you make double
stranded DNA which can be then
transcribed to our mRNA
it's there that can be made into
proteins then the genome has to
replicate you know that we came in with
single stranded DNA so we have to make
more of that to put into new virion so
the genome is replicated to plus and
minus strands and then it's packaged
into capsids
so that's all embodied in this one
figure at the top and then on the bottom
are two examples of the genomes that
we've shown up here the Sirico viridi or
single-stranded circles it tells you the
size but I don't expect you to memorize
genome sizes
I just want to give you a sense for how
much it varies so circular
single-stranded DNA degree of dependence
on the host how did the gene expression
works and some other features which
might be of interest and unless I point
these out in lecture you won't need to
know those and here's another kind of
virus with a linear single-stranded
genome with interesting structures at
the end and we'll talk about how those
work so this is in the chapter for all
seven genome types so I would have a
look at that and I think if you just
start with the seven genome types
memorized you'll be able to deduce
everything else from it so here are the
seven classes I just want to go through
them one by one and talk about how they
work the double stranded DNA gapped
double-stranded so you can put them into
two columns we have our DNA and RNA and
single-stranded DNA genomes and then we
have RNA genomes double stranded RNA
single strands of plus or minus polarity
and then our plus RNA viruses that go
through a DNA intermediate the
retroviruses okay that's where the name
comes from retro because they go from
RNA to DNA whereas for many years we
always thought the flow of genetic
information was DNA to RNA to protein
but this was the wrong way what's not
the wrong way it was discovered my
expectation when you are done with this
course you will know the general answers
to these questions for each genome type
so this is what I want you to know what
are the steps to mRNA production from
each genome if I say I give you a
single-stranded DNA genome how do you
get to mRNA it's easy you tell me well
you make a double-stranded DNA copy and
then you transcribe that to make mRNA
and depending on the virus you can
divide we will either use viral enzymes
or host cell enzymes so those are the
steps what general gene products must
function at each step so to make
single-stranded DNA into double-stranded
DNA the host will do that for most of
these small viruses and then to make
mRNA from DNA it depends on the virus
some viruses we use host enzymes and
some viruses will use your own when in
the life cycle is mRNA made so DNA virus
when they first come in there's no mRNA
present so they have to make it and they
can either make it earlier or later
other viruses come in RNA viruses
they're already mrna so it doesn't have
to be made initially how's the genome
copied what kind of enzymes are used
what kind of replication proteins again
are they viral proteins or host proteins
and which proteins can produce mRNA and
how is this information converted to
gene products for the most part we have
a single mRNA that's translated into
protein but as we'll see in the
translation lecture there are many
variations on that that viruses have
devised I would also suggest you you
look at Appendix A this is full of
figures like this this is a replication
cycle of a hep adenovirus and it shows
you all the steps and you get a very
nice overview of what has to occur so
you can see the viral genome coming in
and it's getting into the nucleus and
you'll find out in the lecture that all
the gaps in this genome are repaired
because can you do you think you could
make mRNA from a gapped DNA
double-stranded DNA just guess no you
can't because you can't make it from
single-stranded DNA template you can't
make it from gap so you have to repair
it and then this can be transcribed and
translated into proteins so you'll see
here viral life cycles some facts about
the genome and you can relate the simple
strategies to the life cycles in this
way you can say okay I start with a
single-stranded or double stranded or
gap gene on what do I have to do it's
all summarized right here I think that
helps a lot so let's look at some of
these genomes one by one the first or
the are the DNA genomes as you know our
genome is based on DNA we've already
said that so many DNA viruses for the
most part emulate what we do with our
DNA but viral DNA genomes are mostly not
like cell chromosomes some of them have
features of cell chromosomes but they
are not like our chromosomes so I would
prefer if you did not call them
chromosomes but I understand that it may
be engrained in your lexicon but they're
not chromosomes unexpected tricks have
evolved which we don't find in cellular
genes and we'll point those out so some
questions too
you thinking about DNA genomes how many
ways can you think to replicate DNA do
DNA viruses always replicate in the
nucleus well you know a virus if a virus
is going to use host DNA replication
enzymes it has to go into the nucleus
because that's where they are but some
viruses don't have to do that and will
tell you how to figure out which ones do
it and which ones don't most cells in
your body are terminally differentiated
in fact do not replicate their DNA so
what happens to a DNA virus that needs
the enzymes of the cell when they try
and infect one of these cells will tell
you what happens there but these are
interesting questions to think about
already do DNA genomes always encode
their own DNA polymerase are there
viruses with DNA genomes that encode no
DNA polymerase and will answer all of
these in the coming weeks but I think
these are quite interesting and finally
do DNA genomes exist that do not require
a DNA polymerase to copy them so let's
start with double stranded DNA genomes
there are 22 families of viruses I'd
never ask you how many families of
double-stranded DNA viruses there are
but I just want to give you a sense of
how many families this is probably an
underestimate because we're discovering
viruses by the hundreds now and they're
probably many more families here are
some of these viruses adeno verde these
are all family names have had no viridi
herpes papilloma polly oma pox we'll
talk about some of these and how they
replicate and cause disease the topology
of the genome is critical for the life
cycle so DNA double stranded DNA genomes
can be linear or circular and these
topologies as you'll see have major
implications for replication I've
already told you one if they're
single-stranded you have to become
double stranded before you can make mRNA
making mRNA information extraction mRNA
is produced when either a host or a
viral enzyme copies the minus strand
I remember in a double stranded DNA the
plus strand is is the strand that's the
same polarity as mRNA so that means to
make mRNA you have to copy the minus
strand right so remember that it can be
confusing you cannot make mRNA from
single strand DNA
which I have already told you and you
can only make it from double-stranded
DNA so single-stranded DNA or gapped DNA
you cannot make mRNA from so you can
immediately deduce that you have to sort
out how to get to a double-stranded DNA
template for that so here are some
double stranded DNA genomes here in the
virion they're double stranded DNA
molecules they can be either circular or
linear here's an example of a family
polyomavirus is in the papilloma viruses
which have circular double-stranded DNA
genomes the add no viruses herpes or pox
virus have Puck's viruses have linear
double-stranded DNA genomes these can be
transcribed directly into mRNA so that's
the first thing that can happen in a
Cell the DNA is copied to mRNA proteins
are made and depending on the virus some
of those proteins participate in DNA
replication some of the biggest viruses
can encode their own DNA replication
systems but many need help from the host
and some proteins have to be made so
then it's very simple you make mRNA from
the DNA you make proteins that
participate in replication regulation of
the cycle and eventually formation of
veer eons so those are double stranded
DNA s we have double stranded DNA s
which are gapped the gap DNA genomes and
these are the genomes of the Hypatia
viruses the human pathogen here is
hepatitis B virus which causes liver
infection
serious human pathogen these have a very
interesting genome which is schematized
here first of all there's a protein
covalently linked to the five prime end
of one strand so in the book you know in
all my slides I have color conventions
so DNA is always blue one strand is
lighter color than the other RNA is
green two different colors four plus and
minus and then proteins are some kind of
earth tone I think but the nucleic acid
is important so you can see here this is
double-stranded DNA you can see there's
a gap here you can also see this protein
linked to the five prime end of one of
the strands and also there is a piece of
RNA linked to one of the strands as well
short piece of RNA you can tell it's
green so
that's the gap DNA with short RNA so one
strand is complete this light blue
strand the minus strand is complete and
the other is only about half completed
so that's why we call it a gapped DNA so
that can't make mRNA as we've already
said when it comes into the cell it has
to be repaired and as far as we know
that uses cellular enzymes so that
pattern of virus DNA genome is repaired
converted to double-stranded DNA so
repair means you take off the protein
you take off the RNA you fill in the gap
because you need perfectly duplex
DNA double stranded DNA in order to make
mRNA so you have to remove those RNA and
protein you have to fill in the gap and
close the ends make sure they're ligated
together and then all that has to happen
before mRNA and this DNA genome we will
see in a subsequent lecture how it's
produced during replication why it ends
up with proteins and RNAs and gap but
the enzyme that is involved in the
replication of this virus is also a
reverse transcriptase very similar to
the enzymes that are used by
retroviruses to copy their RNA genomes
into DNA all right so here's our
double-stranded gap DNA genome just to
give you the whole scheme you start with
this gap genome with the RNA and the
protein linked you repair it and then it
can be used to make mRNA which is used
to make proteins now a curious thing
happens during the life cycle which you
couldn't predict so this is something
you'll just have to know there is
another kind of RNA made by
transcription which serves not as a
template for protein synthesis but for
making first a negative strand of DNA
and then as a double strand of DNA
that's eventually what will get
incorporated into the virion so that's
the reverse transcriptase that takes
this RNA and makes it into DNA now this
is really baroque right you would say
why does this virus do this because
there are other ways to get replication
done right we don't know the answer it
works that's that's what I always fall
back on whatever works for viruses in an
evolutionary sense is there so this has
survived eons of selection and that's
all we can say about it
single stranded the
Genomes there are five viral families in
one genus and there are viruses that
maybe you've heard of the parvo viruses
if you have a dog or a cat you have to
get them vaccinated to prevent parvo
virus infection can kill them circo's
you may not know much about but probably
all of you are infected with one of
these viruses and you're fine because
they don't seem to cause any disease
they have single stranded DNA genomes
and of course as we said they cannot be
made into RNA so we have to make them
double-stranded before we can make mRNA
now these are very small genomes so the
only reason you might want to learn that
these genomes are small because if
they're small they're very unlikely to
encode a DNA polymerase so these genomes
usually encode a protein that is used to
build the capsid and one other protein
that's somehow involved in in
replication but is not a DNA polymerase
so these small circle virus parvovirus
genomes don't encode DNA polymerases so
that means they need to use the host DNA
polymerase so now what can you tell me
about where the divine DNA goes when it
first infects the cell so it's
single-stranded where do you think it
has to go so they can't make mRNA until
it's made double-stranded so where do
you think it has to go to the nucleus
because that's where the enzymes are
that replicates so that's what I mean by
applying a few facts you can logically
think through these processes so all
replication in these virus is
accomplished by cellular DNA polymerases
which are in the nucleus so that's where
these viruses have to go so here we are
single stranded DNA genomes in our
chapter 3 scheme single-stranded DNA is
converted to double-stranded DNA by a
cellular polymerase that happens in the
nucleus you make mRNA in the nucleus now
you wouldn't be able to guess this but
if a virus doesn't encode of this size
doesn't think code a DNA polymerase it's
not likely to encode an enzyme to make
mRNA as well and these don't
so these transcriptase is the enzymes
that copy DNA into mRNA are present are
the ones used from the cell and they're
present in the nucleus so we make viral
proteins to make to do more replication
and make
and make more infectious Furion's the
circle viruses have a single-stranded
circular DNA genome it's very small one
it's among the smallest DNA genomes that
we know about yeah
well some of these viruses actually
package both strands so in some cases
you use them if it's a double-stranded
DNA of course both strand goes into the
virion but I think the good fraction of
these are actually used and those are
not they're degraded yeah yes so the
smaller viruses don't encode the DNA
polymerase or a DNA dependent RNA
polymerase to the enzyme that makes mRNA
I have to remember to repeat the
questions so you can hear them on the
tape okay so this is single stranded DNA
small these are slightly larger the
parvo viruses and as I said the circles
are ubiquitous you're all sural positive
for these viruses but we don't know that
they cause any disease the parvo virus
is do cause human disease called v
disease and it's a rash like disease and
a rash disease of humans and they're
also just cause disease of cats and dogs
they have a very unusual genome
structure which we will talk about when
we talk about DNA replication now about
viruses with RNA genomes now cells these
are unusual and because cells have no
enzymes that can copy these genomes so
it's a little easier for you to remember
how they work just remember that RNA
cannot really be copied by cells I say
really you may think what is he
qualifying there the cells can copy
short pieces of RNA right they can make
micro RNAs and hold the whole small RNA
system in cells is made by copying small
pieces of RNA but they can't copy RNA
genomes whatever enzymes do that cannot
copy big viral genome so what well
that's why we say cells have no
polymerase to replicate these genomes
and to make mRNA so they have to all use
their own enzymes these viruses no
matter how
well they are if they have an RNA genome
they have to encode an enzyme to copy it
so they encode novel polymerases novel
meaning the cell doesn't have anything
like it so if you make an inhibitor of
that polymerase it's a good antiviral
drug or in print in principle it's a
good antiviral drug because the cell
doesn't have anything like it whereas
DNA polymerases of viruses are quite
similar to cellular polymerases and
there can be some effective antiviral
drugs that target viral DNA polymerase
is on the host cell so these RNA
polymerase is encoded by these viruses
they replicate the RNA genome and they
make mRNA and we will talk about this in
detail so you want just to tell you that
you don't have to understand it at that
point they're two different processes
the mRNA of course has to be read by
ribosomes otherwise you can't make
proteins so we have all sorts of
configurations of RNA too we have double
stranded RNA and there are seven virus
families with viruses of double stranded
RNA genomes many of them are segmented
we come back to this word fragmented
I'll show you a picture of a segmented
genome but not all of them are some of
them are uni molecular one RNA in the
virion
here's an example of a virus family with
segments that RNA these are the real
viruses they have ten to twelve
secretary and 'add RNA and these include
rotaviruses which are huge causes of
gastroenteritis
there's also another family that infects
in vertebrates with two segments so the
ros have between ten and twelve and I
don't mean by saying ten to twelve that
within a given virus some of them have
ten and some of them have twelve it's
just within a certain species of virus
within this family some will always have
ten and others will always have 12
doubles here's another factoid which is
good so single-stranded DNA cannot be
transcribed into mRNA double stranded
RNA cannot be translated by ribosomes
even though there is a plus strand in
that double stranded RNA cannot be
accessed by ribosomes they don't know
what to do with this double strand so
there's no enzyme to pull that apart so
the viruses have to
a way to make a plus strand a
single-stranded plus strand from this
duplex RNA so here is an example of a
real virus with 11 double stranded RNA
segments so this is a segmented genome
they are they are here in this case 3 6
9 there are two more not shown here 11
segments and they're all packaged into
the virus particle so you need all of
them for infectivity and again because
the double stranded RNA can't be
translated the first thing that has to
happen is you make mRNA which can be
made into protein and that can be used
to make more RNA and more variants so
you see again what I mean by a few facts
leading you to figure out how the
replication works single stranded RNA
viruses with a plus strand RNA genome
there are a lot of families like this 22
that we know of eight of them have
viruses that infect mammals in our
significant pathogens so the big corner
virus poliovirus and Rhino virus are
significant human pathogens the khaleesi
vos is causing gastroenteritis Astral
viruses also gastroenteritis SARS
coronavirus and then there are
flaviviruses of medical importance
yellow fever West Nile hepatitis C virus
it included in this classification are
retroviruses but there are actually a
separate category in the Baltimore
system that includes HIV and htlv and
then rubella and it's other encephalitis
viruses are also in this categorization
so here's how these viruses work the
genome is plus strand so it can be
translated it can be made translated
into protein so the genome comes in the
cell protein is immediately made and
that protein is eventually used to make
more Furion's the genome has to
replicate and to do that it has to go
through a negative strand intermedia so
that's the way nucleic acids work as you
know to be replicated you make a copy of
one of the strands and the same goes on
with RNA viruses you take the plus
strand genome you make a full-length
minus strand copy which has
no function other than being a template
for the synthesis of more plus strands
so eventually those minus strands are
degraded they're not used because
they're not packaged any further what
goes into the variants or the plus
strands so these are some examples of
these genomes some of them are very long
the coronaviruses where SARS as a member
28 to 33 kilobases these are the longest
RNA virus genomes that we know of and
this is an interesting question why is
there a little dis limit on RNA the size
of RNA genomes DNA viral genomes can be
1.2 million bases long but this is the
biggest for RNA is 33 kilobases we're
not quite sure why they have unusual
features at the ends of the genome which
we'll talk about here for the for
example the book or no viruses have a
protein link to the end many but not all
these are also poly ventilated so these
are messenger rnas they roughly look
like mRNAs in the cell they have a cap
in a poly a but again not all of them do
the Flavie viruses don't have a poly a
the 3-prime and the popcorn of viruses
don't have a cap at the 5-prime end so
this is what I mean by viruses doing
unusual things and we'll talk about what
how those things work later on so one of
these viruses that we had on the
previous slides were single-stranded
plus rnas that go through a DNA
intermediate so there's one viral family
that fits that description the retro
viridi and there are two pathogens in
there HIV and htlv maybe there are more
there's another being considered but
we're not sure yet and the strategy is
remarkable only because when it was
discovered which was in the 70s nothing
like it had ever been seen before so the
plus stranded RNAs and the virion now
here is a little exception to your logic
you would say well that has to be
translated into protein because it's
plus stranded RNA well in fact for these
viruses and that's something you'll just
have to remember that plus stranded
genome does not get translated so it's
not translated in the cell and it gets
copied into a minus strand DNA copy by
an enzyme in the virus particle the
reverse transcriptase it's then made
double-stranded and now that you have a
stranded DNA now you can make mRNA right
and you can make mRNA that can be made
into protein and you can also make RNA
that goes into the genome so the RNA the
virion is a real our mRNA plus stranded
looks just like an mRNA if you extracted
it from the genome you could translate
it into protein but it's never used as a
message in infected cells it's converted
to DNA by this enzyme reverse
transcriptase and what's more
interesting here this double stranded
DNA copy is not floating around in the
cell and then copied into mRNA as is the
DNA genome of many other viruses but
this DNA integrates into the genome of
the host cell and they're the host RNA
polymerase copies it to make mRNA we
will go through that in a separate
lecture entirely but it's very different
from the way all the other viruses
replicate so the pro viral DNA and probe
viral means the DNA copy of the virus
that's integrated into the host cell
that serves as the template for mRNA
synthesis and in fact viral genome
synthesis so here this DNA copy is
integrated in your chromosomal DNA in
fact all of you have these in your
genomes fortunately they are not making
retroviruses they're mutated extensively
but you all have these and in other
animals where they're not extensively
mutated they make mRNA and they make
another copy of RNA that gets
incorporated into variants and that's
done by the cellular polymerase so then
we move to some minus strand RNA viruses
there are seven virus families with
negative sense RNA and these are some of
the mammalian viruses measles and mumps
you may recognize rabies Ebola Marburg
influenza and Lassa virus is some of
these very serious human pathogens now
the minus strand RNA you can predict
that when it gets into a host cell you
know it can't be translated by
definition because it's minus strand so
what has to happen it has to be copied
into a plus strand and in addition
because you know that cells cannot copy
RNA that copying has to be done by a
viral enzyme
so knowing again knowing a few things
you can predict what is going to happen
so these negative stranded RNAs are
copied to mRNA by the virion enzyme
which is then translated into protein
and of course you need to make more
negative strand RNAs to put into
variants and those are done through a
replicative cycle through a plus
stranded intermediate in these enzymes
by the way that copy this have to be in
the virion itself because if it's if
this negative strand came into a cell
without the enzyme nothing would happen
even if the enzyme were encoded in the
genome the cell cannot access the coding
potential in that genome because it's a
minus strand so the enzymes have to be
in the particle so I could say to you
you have a negative strand virus with a
single stranded RNA genome negative
polarity what is in the particle and you
can tell me there's an enzyme to copy
that you will absolutely know that by
automatically knowing these facts so
there's no again there are no enzymes in
the cell that can make RNA so we have to
use it but we have to use a viral
polymerase to do that and that
polymerase makes mRNAs and it also
replicates the genome which means
basically it makes a full-length plus
strand that is not a message it's
reserved for replication and those are
templates for making the minus strand
RNA genomes so here are some
configurations of genomes of single
strand RNA - sense viruses some of them
are segmented just like those real virus
genomes were set the question yeah
so the retroviruses have single stranded
RNA genomes of plus polarity well as
that's all we know of yeah we haven't
discovered any minus polarity but if you
had a reverse transcriptase in the
particle it's theoretically possible
right because the reverse transcriptase
could copy the negative strand into DNA
so there's no theoretical reason why
that couldn't occur but we've never
found that so we have segmented genomes
so here for example influenza virus
genomes is in six to eight segments so
again influenza A viruses have eight
segments of RNA you need all of them in
the virus to be infectious they're all
single-stranded and we have some viruses
with non-segmented genomes paramyxovirus
--is mumps measles virus rabies virus
are all single-stranded RNA genomes so
two different configurations now having
a segmented genome allows you to do
something that viruses that don't have a
segmented genome can do what am I saying
it allows you to do things that genomes
that are not segmented cannot do right
and that is something called
reassortment so when these are two
different influenza viruses infecting a
cell and when these two viruses infect
the cell each of them has eight RNA
segments and they can all read mix
within the cell and they replicated so
you have a mixture of sixteen different
RNA segments from two different viruses
so the viruses that are produced can be
either of the two parental viruses or or
viruses that have mixed segments they
all have to have eight and they all have
to have eight specific segments but they
can come from either parent virus so
this is a way that these viruses undergo
genetic mixing if you will and it's
called reassortment all right so it's a
very specific term it applies to
segmented viruses
now when nucleic acids recombine you
probably have learned this in other
courses you could have DNA recombination
breakage and review
DNA or copy choice mechanisms that allow
the shuffling of pieces or sequences of
DNA among different organisms but
viruses have another way to do it with
having a segmented genome these can
readily mix and the frequency is higher
because you don't need breakage you
don't need copy choice in order to do
this so this happens with influenza and
it's probably a major reason why these
viruses have been with us for many years
and it's very hard to get rid of them
some of the - strand RNA viruses are
called ambi sense that is they have both
plus and minus aspects and there are two
families of viruses Arina Veera day and
Bunya Verity and the last viruses are in
the arena of the verity families are
very serious viruses that cause
hemorrhagic fever highly fatal but
largely restricted to a few countries of
the world so here's what these genomes
look like and B cents RNA genomes so you
can see I think the two colors of RNA we
have our light green color and so this
is kelly green and this is olive green
okay and that's because there are two
different polarities we have the plus
cents here and then the rest of the
genome is minus cents so it's actually a
mixture of polarity so this part of the
genome could be translated but not this
part because it's negative polarity so
this virus that we're illustrating here
has a genome of two RNA segments an else
segment and an S segment they're both
ambi cents and they encode two proteins
for each segment and what happens is
when these aren't when these viruses
infect the cell the first thing that in
fact happens is that the vie there's a
viral enzyme in the particle that makes
a small mRNA complimentary to this
negative sequence at the three prime end
so in the olive green part is minus
strand so you can't translate it so a
virus enzyme makes an mRNA which is now
the plus strand that can be translated
into protein on the other hand the five
the sequences at the five prime end can
be directly accessed but they're not in
fact a copy of this whole genome
to be made so now this goes from plus to
minus and then this is copied into an
mRNA from which proteins can be made and
probably the reason this isn't
translated is because there's no cap
here at the 5-prime end so that's an
example of a segment that has both kinds
of polarities in it and I don't know why
these have arisen again they exist they
volution airily that i've survived so
it's a strategy that works so here's a
nice figure that summarizes everything
there's a very good site over in
Switzerland here's the URL which
basically classifies viruses it has lots
of very nice graphics such as this one
so it has our seven groups of DNA genome
of a viral genome all the DNA and RNA
types with nice illustrations and they
have a little cartoon above and in fact
these are links that you can click on
and go to descriptions of each of the
different kinds and you can see the flow
of information from the genome through
the intermediate to mRNA and eventually
to protein so this is another way of
summarizing what we've been talking
about it's a modern view of the
baltimore scheme now in the virus
particle one of the genomes look like
i've been drawing these linear diagrams
but those are mainly illustrative of
course we don't think this is what the
RNA looks like in a particle we don't
really know what the RNA or DNA genome
looks like because we can't see its
structure it seems to be largely
disordered inside and when it is
disordered you can't you don't know what
the structure is but there have been
some predictions which suggests that the
genomes of some RNA viruses are all
folded up and look like something like
this so the RNA I showed you first this
RNA this is a Pokorny virus RNA about 7
and 1/2 kilo bases long in reality this
may be in the virus particle folded up
in this way and here is the very first
base of the RNA here where this arrow is
so this is called RNA secondary
structure we'll talk about this more
later on but it's likely that in the
particle genomes aren't linear they're
folded in a variety of ways that are
important for function and in the text
there is a table I think this is in
Chapter three which shows some of the
different configurations Geno
take on so we've already seen these very
interesting parvo viral genomes the
gapped DNA's of padna viruses Koerner
viruses genomes which are highly
structured here and here and a variety
of others showing interesting structures
these all have functions in replication
some of which we'll talk about in detail
but it just serves to illustrate that in
the particle the genome is in a very
specific configuration it's not just the
line a squiggly line that I've drawn on
the screen now I want to talk a little
bit about how we use genetic methods to
study viruses and what we can do with
that and a few terms that we need to set
forth because we'll use these a lot
wildtype we use often this means the
original virus from which you select
mutants it's often a laboratory adapted
virus we call it wild-type because it's
our starting material but it's really an
arbitrary name because we know now that
you can take clinical isolates from
different individuals and they'll all be
slightly different so it's an old term
which probably isn't accurate anymore
this may or may not be identical to a
virus you isolate from nature but we use
it as a starting point now when you get
virus isolates from a natural host we
call them field or clinical isolates so
often I'll be talking about a clinical
ISIL and that's what I mean something
directly taken from an individual as
opposed to a virus that's used in the
laboratory for many years and has been
passaged extensively some of the methods
we use in viral Egeus in addition to the
ones we talked about the other day these
pertain to the genomes one important one
is called DNA mediated transformation
and this is the introduction of foreign
DNA into cells and the reason why it has
a long name DNA mediated transformation
is because before this it was
appreciated that you could put DNA into
cells and change their phenotypes hence
the word transformation it had already
been the word had already been used to
show to describe oncogenic
transformation the transformation of
cells into an oncogenic phenotype so
hence not to confuse the two we put DNA
mediated
transformation in front now this is the
abstract of the 1944 paper from Avery
MacLeod in McCarthy at Rockefeller which
showed that you could transform the
morphology of a bacterium in this case a
pneumococcus using DNA so they took two
different colony morphologies here the
two different morphologies a small one
in a large shiny one and they could
transform one to the other by taking the
DNA of one strain and putting it into
the other and this was the first proof
that DNA was the genetic material so you
see they called it transformation of
pneumococcal types and that's where the
word DNA mediated transformation came
from now nowadays we use another term
transfection transfection specifically
refers to the production of virus after
you put viral DNA into cells so you take
viral DNA purified viral DNA you
introduce it into cells that's DNA
mediated transformation and that
initiates an infectious cycle so that's
called transfection because it's
transformation and infection
transfection but unfortunately people
don't really like to say DNA mediated
transformation all the time so they say
transfection for everything so you take
a gene encoding a protein of any kind
and you express it in a cell by putting
DNA in the cell they call it
transfection it's not really correct but
you will hear everyone including Nobel
laureates using it so I just want to
explain what is the correct usage of the
term transfection really refers to
initiating a viral infection with
nucleic acid mutation of course is a
change in DNA or an RNA based changes
insertions deletions and rearrangements
we'll talk a lot about mutation in this
course nonsense mutation missense
mutations but it is not a change in
protein if you say i mutated the protein
that's not right because mutation means
you're working on nucleic acid and this
is again something that people don't use
correctly so I want to tell you the
proper usage mutation is for nucleic
acid what method allowed the application
of genetic
methods to animal viruses anyone wish to
hazard a guess yeah if you print it out
the lecture notes the answer is right
there what is that what cell cults your
health but there's another more specific
assay you see that circle what is that
picture plaque assay it allows you to
pick genetically pure cultures of a
virus right you need to be able to do
that to do genetics if you can't purify
a virus clone it you can't do genetics
so that's the plaque assay is crucial
for this so that's why I was such a big
deal when renato dulbecco devised the
plaque assay for animal viruses in 1952
it allowed you to isolate mutants of
various sorts and how did we do that
back then well it turns out that for RNA
viruses if you grow up an RNA virus
stock you have a tube of an RNA virus
it's full of mutants already because the
polymerase makes mistakes it makes about
one mistake in ten thousand or a hundred
thousand bases that it polymerizes so
many RNA virus genomes are ten thousand
bases in length so that means that every
time it's replicated one mistake is made
so a stock of virus which has billions
of viruses in it is a wonderful
collection of mutants DNA viruses don't
make as many mistakes several orders of
magnitude higher so there are fewer
mutants but they're still there you just
have to work harder and in some cases
you mutagenize the viruses with
chemicals that introduce mutations so
that you can get mutants where you can't
otherwise so some of the mutations that
were used or listed here nitrous acid
hydroxyl amine and alkylating agents
they modify the DNA such that when the
replication occurs you get miss pairing
so if you find any of these chemicals
anywhere don't ingest them they're very
mutagenic they will cause mutations in
your DNA there are also base analogs
that cause changes in DNA during
replication UV also does that as well so
all of these were used to mute
nice viruses to induce mutations when
you couldn't find them naturally in a
stock of virus yeah howdy
let's say you take a tube of virus and I
give you a tube of RNA virus and I say
make some get some mutants out of here
for me what would you do well you can
screen for phenotypes you would ask me
well what do you want what kind of
mutant do you want well you could say
give me a temperature-sensitive mutant
that is give me a virus that doesn't
grow it at high temperature like 39
degrees we usually grow viruses at 37
centigrade I say give you give me a
virus that doesn't grow at 39 now so
that's easy to screen for in your
collection of mutants you could say how
about a plaque sized mutant how about a
tiny plaque or a bigger plaque or some
morphological alteration in the plaque
size cold-sensitive mutants viruses that
don't grow at low temperatures you can
make readily devised screens to select
out of that tube of RNA viruses or your
DNA virus treated with a chemical of
some sort these kinds of mutants drug
resistance escape2 antibodies there are
lots of examples of phenotypes that you
can search for but nowadays we don't
really do this except maybe in drug
discovery because we use we actually
engineer mutation into the genome so we
say we have a viral genome we're going
to put a mutation exactly where we want
it and see what the phenotype is and
this is because we now have what are
called infectious DNA clones for just
about every virus that we work with we
have DNA copies of their genomes which
we can modify very specifically and get
exactly what we want and this is a
modern validation of the hershey-chase
experiment which you may remember from
the other day I remember hershey-chase
said that the genome contained the
information to make new particles so if
you take a DNA copy of the genome and
you put it in the cell and you get virus
out that validates hershey-chase in a
different way and you can make all kinds
of mutations in these DNA copies is to
use recombinant DNA methods the the sky
is the limit it could do whatever you
want there's hershey-chase which we
talked about the other day so we have
infectious DNA clones for basically all
viruses DNA viruses which are all shown
here
RNA viruses plus and minus strand double
stranded RNA let me show you two
examples of how you do this
here's polio virus polio has a plus
stranded RNA genome when the RNA gets
into a cell it can be translated so if
you extract the RNA from polio virus and
transfected into cultured cells you will
initiate an infectious cycle so the RNA
is infectious
you can take this RNA and make a
double-stranded DNA copy of it and clone
it into a plasmid and then use the
plasmid to make RNA in vitro with
various enzymes and then you can take
that RNA and put it into cells and you
will get virus again because this is
very much like the viral RNA this is
great because you can modify this DNA
again you can mutate it you can add
bases subtract them change them you
could add sequences from other viruses
can do whatever you want you can't do
that with RNA so we can we can do
genetics having DNA copies of viral
genomes to do the same thing with
influenza virus influenza virus has
eight negative stranded RNA segments so
what you have to do for that virus is
you have to clone each of the eight RNA
segments into a plasmid and then you
engineer the plasmid which is shown in a
linear way here to make both plus and
minus strand copies of the RNA the
reason you have to do that we don't need
to go into but basically you take eight
plasmids each plasmid encoding a one of
the viral RNAs you put those into cells
eight plasmid transfection and you get
virus out so again with influenza you
can do the same thing as with the corn
of viruses you can make changes in the
virus and see what their effect is now
this technique was used to rescue the
flu virus of 1918 we didn't have cell
culture in 1918 you know there was a
huge pandemic back then millions of
people died but we don't have the virus
from it so it's a shame we would like to
study it so what people did was they
resurrected it was we didn't it we
didn't have flu until 1933 in 2005 viral
RNA was isolated from formalin-fixed
lung samples from someone who had died
in 1918 so the army you know a lot of
military people died of flu
1918-19 and whenever they died the army
would take sections of their lungs and
they would put them away very good at
keeping these sections they're all in
order so if someone went back to those
archives took some of those sections on
slides and took off the tissue and
extract and RNA got the sequence of the
RNA they also got RNA from someone who
had died of flu in 1918 and they were
buried up in Alaska was the ground is
frozen all the time so they opened the
grave and they did a biopsy of the lung
and they took the tissue extracted the
RNA in sequence did so they could
reconstruct the sequence of the entire
virus so they made eight plasmids of the
1918 virus put those into cells and they
got the 1918 virus out complete sequence
and virus has recovered of course you
have to study this under very high
containment you can't just do it up the
street here you have to do it in a bsl-3
facility because it it's a very lethal
virus but this shows you how you can
reconstruct viruses from viruses that we
don't even have anymore now the other
thing you can do with having cloned
viral genomes and the ability to
resurrect viruses from DNA is you can
make vectors and vectors are good for
research but they can also be used to
treat human diseases so congenial goal
is to deliver a gene to patients who
lack it or have a mutation and you can
use viral vectors to do that so one way
to do it is to take cells from a patient
infect them with a virus vector that
expresses the gene and then put them
back into the patient you can use these
vectors to deliver antigens in other
words you can make a viral vaccine from
such vectors and we use them in the
research lab as well these vectors have
to have a certain capacity for foreign
nucleic acid if it's low it's not good
they can't cause disease of course you
don't want to cure someone's genetic
disease and kill them with the vector
obviously and you have to have a
promoter that is a sequence in the
vector that makes RNA in the right
tissues and cells so here are just some
examples of genetic diseases that could
be treated using viral vectors
we know for each disease what the defect
is seems to be a single gene so for
example hemophilia a factor seven
deficiency cystic fibrosis the defective
salt transporter so in theory you can
give patients the gene the functional
gene to restore function and take away
the disease in practice this has been
very difficult to do for a variety of
reasons but there have been a few
successes some of the vectors that are
used a lot or adenovirus vectors these
are large viruses you can put a lot of
foreign sequence in them and in fact you
can cut out most of the viral genome
from these and put in foreign sequence
and we may talk about some examples of
how these are used the other vectors
that are commonly used are retrovirus
vectors this is these are viruses
remember with a plus stranded RNA genome
they encode a variety of proteins but
what you can do with retroviruses is you
can put the proteins on separate
plasmids and reconstitute particles so
for example here we have two different
plasmids one plasmid is encoding the
capsid protein and another is encoding
what we call the envelope glycoprotein
so you'll you'll understand all of this
better after a few more lectures if we
put both of these plasmids into cells we
get empty virus particles without
genomes but we can put a third plasmid
in here which say encodes of a gene of a
human that you want to correct and now
you will have retroviruses containing
the foreign gene and this lentiviruses
which are a kind of retrovirus are used
for gene therapy applications as well
they infect many different cell types
and this is an example of lentiviral
gene therapy to treat a neurologic
disease this is called x-linked adrenal
leukodystrophy it's caused by a defect
in a gene report needed for a
transporter function so you can restore
the function of this gene by giving
patients the gene without the mutation
so what was done in two patients with
this gene is they took bone marrow from
these individuals and put them in
culture and then infected them with a
lentivirus that expressed the gene that
they needed and then the cultures were
allowed to expand
and then put back into the patient and
in these two individuals they showed
regression of the disease as shown by
these x-rays after a period of time so
this is actually the first very
successful use of gene therapy which
just happened in November 2009 but it's
an example of what you can do with viral
vectors and this all comes from being
able to clone viral genomes and have
them express as viruses when you put
them themselves
you